welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who
wants to be inside Charlotte Hale like
Dolores is and this video were breaking
down the latest Westworld entry with the
penultimate episode right around the
corner
things are really ramping up and this
season seems to be getting better and
better with each addition throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the latest entry and giving our
thoughts about what's going on in the
show there will of course be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't had a chance
to check our episode six-year and don't
want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel
because we do fan theories and
breakdowns on the show week by week and
you don't want to miss any of the
updates without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Westworld
I've had to make some difficult choices
okay so firstly the title of the episode
decoherence potentially brings a lot
with it I believe it's a play on the
concept of quantum decoherence which
according to Google means as a result of
an interaction the wave functions of a
system and the measuring device become
entangled with each other I have no idea
what that means but basically it's a
breakdown of States due to elements
being kept separate this likely refers
to William who due to his isolation
begins to have a mental breakdown but it
could also refer to Hale and the fact
that Dolores keeps splitting herself
she's spreading herself thin like butter
being scraped over too much toast and
after the death of canals a similar
thing happens to Hale having been
separated from the whole in this episode
she actually diverges a lot from Dolores
and showcases that different experiences
can cause one to have a different
outlook even to oneself who has been
through the exact same experiences
beforehand there's a lot of symbolism
for her breaking free or rather getting
quantum decoherence which we will talk
about as we get further into the video
there's also a copy of Dolores that
states her path has diverted from the
one that is out in the world and yeah
just a lot of things tie back to it
we begin with fields once more and this
has been a motif that has slowly been
laced throughout Westworld serac of
course experienced that last time with
his brother after watching the
destruction of Paris and here Maebh is
in the sublime I'm starting to think
that the fields are literally a
reference to gladiator and though not
necessarily heaven they may depict a
seemingly better life after walking
through the fields Ciroc went on to have
wealth and fortune and Maivia is
reunited with her daughter in the
afterlife both in a way are falsehoods
and serac though rich enough to buy
Amazon doesn't seem too happy mirroring
this may we'll have to betray her on
people to come back here and serac is
almost blackmailing here with the
reunion of her daughter to turn against
the hosts her body is being
reconstructed after being stabbed
through the stomach and from Ciroc she
requests extra help later we see that
there are hosts being printed that will
become her allies and shoutouts to Logan
Lannister
read it for spotting that one of them
had the same number as Clem so yeah she
will be returning maim is back in war
world and with God mode switch back on
she's relishing the power elsewhere is
William aka the man in white
William is at inner journeys this is a
reeducation center scimitar the one that
we saw sir racks brother placed in last
week here the patients all seem to be
questioning their lives whether it's
their purpose reality or Williams
favorite subject existentialism all
those within are going through their own
inner journeys of self-discovery he
rifts on the Agent Smith speech from the
matrix a bit but I loved hearing him
referring to humanity as maggots
feasting upon a corpse this signifies
that he believes the world to be dead
and we will soon have used up all of the
resources and be gone with it he's not
getting along with well anyone even
himself and this episode is very much
about confronting the death of his
daughter and his inner demons he's being
seen by dr. lang whose family are trying
to contact her probably due to the
collapse of the world on the outside of
the facility and how much of a bad
person she is you're evil you're the
biggest villain in West world later in
the scene we will in the hell life
projection states that she will have an
opioid addiction and lose custody of her
children and we'll have multiple affairs
with patients so what is she doing
working at energy anis well personally I
believe that serac has deliberately
chosen people to work there that are
prone to break the law because he needs
them too we recently did a crazy Theory
breakdown video that discussed how Caleb
might actually be sir axe brother and we
determined that the re-education in the
re-education Center title was basically
stripping people of their identity and
holding them within a prison that
reformatted them for society serac wants
to remove the anomalies and strip them
of their memories and so on so that they
can go back to civilization and not be a
problem I think this is why caleb is
experiencing flashbacks to a life he
does not know and why Dempsey said you
did it the people that would be required
to run such a facility probably wouldn't
have the best moral compass and I think
that's why Lange is in such a position
of power
however this early discovery makes her
kill herself which we also saw some sir
contemplating in the last episode that
namely that guys standing and staring at
the sea it was a lovely view though
William too has come face to face with
the fact that his obsession with the
game made him kill his own daughter and
he wishes to die because of it they take
a sample of Williams blood and though we
don't know specifically what this is for
they do detect an unknown protein within
it this is likely from when Hale pin
pricked his neck and in hindsight I
believe this was the tracking device
which now allows them to learn of his
location in the facility
William gets the implant drilled into
his mouth which is a device that the
majority of citizens now where we are
yet to learn the purpose of this fully
but they bring attention to it every
week and it is possible that this is
used to track people's whereabouts
should they leave the facility Caleb had
one on and it was disabled which could
be how his movements with the loris of
going undetected should he be related to
Sarah okay I'll stop with that now I
know it's probably not true but but let
me dream anyway we finally get some time
with Hale who is escorting her son
through San Francisco she passes people
in an alleyway spray-painting a maze
onto a wall and this is of course a nod
to the mace from the park the people
have woken up and discovered that they
are all part of loops I believe this
symbolizes their rebellion and
self-awareness inhales X's apartment we
see a circle painting on the wall this
is similar to the one that was hanging
up in Ciroc room and could showcase just
how much we ho bomb is built-in to
society she sees that jake has lucked up
his profile as he did wish to know what
happened between them however he decided
that it was up to them and not a machine
this is clearly felt deeply by Hale and
the subtext of this scene could be that
Hale feels Dolores is the Machine
controlling hair this is cemented by the
removal of her bracelet later in the
episode which shows that she is being
unshackled from a chains the statue in
her office is also just one person when
she met with Dolores in the hotel room
we saw one of two people being torn
apart which was a metaphor for Dolores
personality being split in two with the
one in the office just being one I think
it does show her evolution and that she
will now be fully operating over own
accord Hale meets with the board member
who wished for privatization of the
company and so racks thugs kill him and
give her a direct line to the character
he is two hours away from acquiring
das and Dolores needs Hale to get the
host making data before this takes place
hail protests for the protection of her
family but Dolores states that they're
not a family which she clearly grapples
with Hale says she can feel herself
moving away and this decoherence will
likely divert her away from a master in
future episodes Ciroc wishes to have all
of Dallas's intellectual property erased
except for the encryption key which
unlocks the guest data and sublime he
knows that there are versions of Dolores
within Delos and he orders everyone to
prove that they're real Hale is caught
copying the hosts data by a board member
but she quickly takes him out because
snitches get stitches
she also discovers that they recovered
canals probe and therefore Dolores which
does pop up later in the episode a
dinner journeys William is going through
the same a our treatment that Caleb once
did and this editing procedure has
likely carried out in order to make him
fit into society once more
William is taken back to his childhood
where we see him reading a book called
sir Rowan and Lady sullen this book
doesn't actually exist but it's clearly
riffing on etherion works the Lady of
Shalott is now the Lady of sullen sir
Kay is now king K and sir Roland is now
sir Rowan I probably butchered all their
names but I believe this taking of the
past and twisting it slightly is a
comment on Westworld itself and which
elements of history such as the Wild
West were taken and repurposed this is
likely where Williams obsession with
revisited fantastical plays on history
likely stem from but before we can learn
more on this he breaks out of it and is
seemingly sent to bed however a big
twist comes when we learn that William
is already within an AR simulation and
this is scented out by the return of
major Craddock who plays an orderly
within his group therapy session he
comes face to face with key versions of
himself from his past and James tell us
on this inner journey sorry again he
tackles with the aspects of his
personality that put him in this
position I'm glad we got Jimmy Simpson
returning and William revisits his
suppressed memories we discovered that
Williams father was a drunk and whilst
it initially seemed that this is what
caused William to be the way that he is
eventually we learn that it's William
that caused his father to be a drunk I
loved the use of the phrase if he
tell doesn't matter and this is a call
back to Angela who said the same thing
to him and during his first visit to
West world it's also what Williams said
to the copy of James tell us in season
two and yeah I do appreciate its
appearance here May believes a pile of
bodies in war world and lease Sizemore
arrives to see what's going on she's
killing time and hosts whilst their body
is reprinted and then moved back to
Dallas she too brings Hector back and
goes to interview the replica of Dolores
in the same room where Dolores
interviewed Bernard it's kind of hinting
at their coming battle and they both
decide that they will have to fight one
another in order to achieve their goals
now may believe that the key to the
sublime is in Dolores his head but I
actually think that it's in Bernards
when we saw Bernards pearl in episode 3
it was laced with red coloring and also
canals told him that he was
irreplaceable there is a reason why
Bernard was the only other house that
Dolores took out and I believe this is
because he's actually the key here in
the board serac reveals that he knows
hail is Dolores due to her actually
checking in on her son sheesh what a
deadbeat mum Sirach says Dolores his own
catchphrase these violent delights have
violent ends and we watch the house from
West world burned up which I can't show
because of Teddy's hail and leashes gas
canister which knocks the board out and
it turns out that serac was just a
hologram this may return and you never
really know if you seeing the real one
or an illusion similar this world which
could all just be a simulation within
Rijo bomb I'll stop with that theory now
Hale gets away she kicks butt and
destroys Hector's pill we also see other
pills one of which is clam but the
others that we don't know there is a lot
of potential for it to be Teddy and
James Marsden has hinted that he will be
back but I guess we will see Dolores his
plan was seemingly always to take out
Maeve's allies through hail and you go
to destroy Maeve I've actually stopped
by God's just before doing so and Hale
takes Dolores his pearl just before
she's captured the big mech from episode
3 rescues her
that's an awesome action scene I love
when westfield pulls things out of the
bag like this another cgi does look a
bit iffy at some points it's awesome
seeing the Hulkbuster take gods out like
that nothing else where William is
killing the other
patience of himself and we see him going
WWE on poor Jimmy William now free from
his past concludes that he is the good
guy in all this it seems like he will be
playing a big part in what's to come
maybe's body is finally created and i
love scene this scene especially the
eyebrow bit because because there are
fleek pale manages to make it back to
her family but they're blown up by one
of Cyrax men however hale manages to
climb out of the wreck
looking like Anakin from Revenge of the
Sith and a single tear rolls down her
face she stares at the wreckage This
Means War now going forward next week's
episode looks like it has a lot going on
in the preview we see a satellite
launched something which could either be
a missile or a probe Caleb's backstory
can also be seen and we learned that he
was taking memory suppressants to hide
from his past we also see that Bernard
and Stubbs have arrived that energy
unease to get William now how they
managed to get there we don't know but I
believe that Stubbs is working for serac
and were there for know the location
this explains how he was able to sneak
into insight last week and say Bernard
and serac did say that he had other
moles so this makes a lot of sense caleb
is seemingly going to get his memory
restored and yeah we'll hopefully find
out that he saw Rock's brother please
please let one of my theories be right
please
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and what your
predictions for the future are comment
below and let us know and if you enjoy
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the series so far we go
through each episode week by week and
also discuss some of the craziest
theories that you might have heard on
this show if you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
or subscribe to the channel and this
month you can win the Marvel phase 3
part 1 box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winner is going to be
chosen at random on the 15th of May and
this will be shipped out from then -
ever gets the prize so best
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]